ces images de drones témoignent de
l'ampleur des dégâts en plein centre
d'Odessa un immeuble résidentiel et une
zone commerciale
défigurée par les frappes russes ici des
vitres soufflées par les explosions
quelques mètres plus loin un entrepôt
entier qui menace de ses fonds
explosion je vis loin d'ici à côté de
l'usine de micro-ondes mais je l'ai
entendu de là-bas
c'est vraiment effrayant on a entendu
les sirènes alertant du danger mais on a
même pas eu le temps de se mettre à
l'abri lorsque l'explosion a retenti
ensuite on s'est caché dans un parking
souterrain c'est terrifiant ces gens ne
sont pas humains
l'oeuvre d'un missile de croisière russe
calibre selon les autorités ukrainiennes
elles affirment en avoir intercepté
trois au total
lancé depuis la mer Noire 4 missiles ont
été tirées sur le centre d'Odessa
en raison des combats aériens une forte
explosion a endommagé plusieurs
immeubles un entrepôt commercial des
magasins là dans cet immeuble il y a eu
plusieurs blessés
la ville portuaire dodesa prisait des
Ukrainiens et des Russes pour leurs
vacances a été bombardé à plusieurs
reprises depuis le début de l'invasion
russe à grande échelle ces derniers
jours l'armée de Vladimir Poutine a
multiplié les frappes sur plusieurs
régions ukrainiennes notamment sur
celles de doniak dans l'Est
écrivitric dans le centre du pays une
campagne de bombardements massif au
moment où les forces ukrainiennes mènent
leur contre-offensive sur plusieurs
fronts avec quelques succès militaires
Kiev revendiquent la reconquête de
plusieurs localités
occupées par les Russes